- [Voiceover] Hello
Grammarians. Hello Paige.
- [Paige] Hi, David.
- [Dave] So we have
three different sentence
varieties that we're
going to talk about today.
- [Paige] Okay.
- [Dave] Here are their three flavors.
Flavor number one, declarative sentences.
Flavor number two,
interrogative sentences.
And flavor number three,
imperative sentences.
Those are all pretty
long and wibbly words.
- [Paige] Seriously.
- [Dave] But we will address
each one of them in turn.
Paige, if you please, what
is a declarative sentence?
- [Paige] A declarative sentence is a type
of sentence that just
states a fact or an opinion,
I suppose, but it just makes a statement.
So that would be something like
it is a beautiful day.
- [Dave] It is a beautiful day, Paige.
We can also use declarative sentences
to get across any kind of information.
This is what we call
exposition in writing.
- [Paige] Righ. Yeah.
- [Dave] So we can say
Lavender hated baseball.
You know, you could start
a short story with that.
- [Paige] Right, that's-
- [Dave] I challenge you to.
- [Paige] Just a fact about Lavender.
- [Dave] That's a fact about Lavender.
So a declarative sentence is a statement.
Just straight up.
- [Paige] Yep.
- [Dave] An interrogative
sentence is a question.
So it asks a question.
- [Paige] It's just a
fancy word for a question.
- [Dave] Right.
- [Paige] Okay.
- [Dave] So an example of
an interrogative sentence
would be where did you go last night?
- [Paige] Right.
- [Dave] Or how is he
still singing that note?
- [Paige] I have no idea.
- [Dave] Incredible breath control
So that's what an
interrogative question is.
- [Paige] Right.
It's like being interrogated.
That's, like, a similar
word to interrogative,
is just having a lot of questions asked.
- [Dave] Like really aggressively.
- [Paige] Yeah, it's not
a very positive thing.
- [Dave] Paige, what did
you do with the cheese?
- [Paige] I don't know. (laughs)
- [Dave] Paige, why are you
still eating the cheese?
- [Paige] I'm not.
- [Dave] Paige, I know
you stole the cheese.
Finally, the third kind of sentence
we want to talk about
today is the imperative.
An imperative is a command.
- [Paige] Right, so when you
tell someone to do something.
- [Dave] So a command like,
Paige, follow that bunny!
(laughs)
- [Paige] And the bunny stole the cheese.
- [Dave] Yeah.
So this is one of those
sentences that doesn't
have a subject that is
literally spoken out loud.
- [Paige] Right, it's just implied.
You know, if you're saying that to me,
I know that I am the subject.
- [Dave] Right. So it's
you follow that bunny.
- [Paige] Right.
- [Dave] But the you is just not spoken.
Or, if you're not into
bunny following, you know,
something like remember
to wash the dishes,
you're still being commanded to remember.
- [Paige] Yeah, yeah.
- [Dave] So, yeah,
that's our, those are our
three sentence types.
- [Paige] Yeah.
Declarative is a statement.
Interrogative is a question,
and imperative is a command.
- [Dave] So, Paige, I think
we can recast our slogan
in each of these three types of sentence.
- [Paige] Okay.
- [Dave] So, okay, so declarative, right?
That's what it usually
is, declarative form is
you can learn anything.
- [Paige] Okay.
- [Dave] We can make it a
question, so interrogative's
can you learn anything?
- [Paige] Right.
- [Dave] The answer is yes.
- [Paige] Yes.
- [Dave] And the imperative,
we wanna make it a command,
would be what, Paige?
- [Paige] Learn anything!
- [Dave] Yeah!
So you can do any of those three.
- [Paige] Sure.
- [Dave] David out.
- [Paige] Paige out.